foreign
good evening everyone
as you probably gathered by now my name
is David Nutt I'm a psychiatrist
neuropsychopharmacologist at Imperial
College London and it's a great pleasure
to talk to you tonight about this topic
the modern state of psychedelic research
but before we get to the present day
let's look back a few thousand years and
understand where psychedelics have come
from and which ones we're talking about
so if you look at this image on the top
left you have the Peyote Cactus which
makes mescaline and then you have the
magic mushrooms which 200 species of
which makes psilocybin top right hand
side you have Ayahuasca this drinkable
form of DMT discovered by the indigenous
peoples of the Amazon
bottom rights you have a different kind
of psychedelic the uh this is the
Amanita mascaris it's a Gaba as opposed
to a serotonergic psychedelic I won't be
talking more about that tonight and then
across the bottom morning glory seeds
Morning Glory which Caesar which contain
a lysergic acid derivative as do the
ergot fungi that grow on rye and the
most important image here is the bottom
left hand one so that's a three thousand
year old Greek virus
and shows the Greek god to meet her
partaking of ergot and wine
and that combination fueled the famous
illusinian Mysteries those celebrations
of Dance Theater art music that were
Central to Greek culture for many
hundreds of years
and after those Mysteries the Greeks
returned to their city-states from their
parties and carried on doing the things
that we know they were good at such as
geometry logic and also the development
of
constructs such as democracy and
since most of Western culture is at some
extent based on the under our
understanding and our appreciation of
those Greek intellectuals you can pick a
reasonable case that psychedelics uh
will party to the whole generation of
Western culture and in fact you can make
similar cases to for the generation of
other cultures as well I don't have the
time to go into that today
if we fast forward now to the beginning
of the modern era we see this quote from
William James one of the founding
fathers of the discipline of psychology
who thought long and hard about the
nature of Consciousness and after taking
mescaline and nitrous oxide he wrote
this
a normal waking consciousness is but one
special type of Consciousness whilst all
about it parted from it by the filmiest
of screens they're like potential forms
of Consciousness entirely different and
then I've highlighted the next bit no
account of the universe in its totality
can be final that leaves these
disregarded and the reason I've
emphasized that because I think that is
a challenge it's 100 years on we're now
able to pick up but understanding the
nature of altered Consciousness is one
of the great challenges of science
equally important as studying the
origins of the universe or the
components of subatomic particles
but how to regard them as the question
for those who discontinuous with
ordinary Consciousness now James
pioneered the use of nitrous oxide in
particular to explore altered um States
Of Consciousness but he didn't have the
Imaging Technologies we have and that's
where the big revolution the modern
revolution in psychedelic understanding
has emerged from
of course in the public Arena this man
really did more than anyone to make
people interested in the nature of
altered Consciousness this is
um Aldous Huxley
who having written about written
dystopian novels like Rave New World
then took mescaline and it changed his
mind and and in such a profound way that
he he sought
to make sense of it using this quote
from the English Mystic and uh painter
and writer William Blake if the doors of
perception were cleansed everything
would appear to man as it is infinite if
a man has closed himself up
till he sees all things through narrow
things of his Cavern and that's why the
books called the doors of perception
because Huxley realized that mescaline
had opened the doors to his perception
but he went beyond that he then thought
well hang on if the doors have been
opened by mescaline something must be
closing them
what is that
and he came to this conclusion the brain
is an instrument for focusing the mind
and mescaline turned off the brain and
allowed the mind to do things
differently and in many cases better
and one of the Wonder Wonders of Our
modern Neuroscience understanding is he
was exactly right
now about the same time as uh Huxley was
trying mescaline this man Albert Hoffman
was making LSD available for researchers
he discovered it in the late 1940s and
he persuaded his company to make it
available for research and this is a
picture of him aged a hundred
and the first British person to
take uh LSD with Joe elky's a
psychiatrist in Birmingham
and I just emphasize the fact that these
early pioneers of psychedelic research
both live to over a hundred and whether
that's
due to the fact that they took LSD is
not proven but it certainly argues
against claims by the CIA and other
groups that drugs like LSD destroy your
brain it's possible they do the opposite
big Tuesday's drug companies like Sando
who often work for were open-minded and
interested in science rather than just
profit and they made LSD available in
that box there those LSD tablets and
they also made psilocybin available
after Hoffman had worked out in 1957
that
was rather similar to LSD in its
chemistry and its um
effects on the brain and these two
different medicines were used by the
psychiatric profession to do various
things like to model psychosis to help
doctors psychiatrists understand what
it's like to have an altered
Consciousness so they could be more
sympathetic with their patients but
particularly
they were used for therapy and there
were two kinds of therapy one called
psychedelic Psychotherapy which is what
we tend to do today which is a big dose
big single dose people have profound
experiences often of a mystical nature
and
out of which they come changed
obviously mostly for the better
that was the approach favored in the U.S
in the UK we're being a little bit more
cautious and we tended to use a lower
dose of these drugs giving a lower dose
before each Psychotherapy session it was
called psycholytic Psychotherapy and the
idea was that these drugs would loosen
the resistance that people had to
engaging in a Psychotherapy and so
benefit from it and we're also doing
that today we're doing a study in
patients with OCD who told us
categorically they will not have a trip
they cannot bear the thought of losing
control even if it might help them so
now we're using low Doses and lower
doses to help them engage better in
their Psychotherapy without having a
full-blown trip and because of the
generosity of Sandown because of the
amazing investment by the U.S National
Institute of Health who funded over 130
grants there was a massive amount of
research done in the 50s and 60s on
these drugs
they were the revolution in Psychiatry
that for the first time Psychiatry had
tools to explore the brain and the mind
and a thousand clinical papers were
published out of 40 000 patients 40
books six International conferences and
in 1971 when all this research was
banned by the UN conventions Masters in
Houston put together an overview coming
to the conclusion that results were
overwhelmingly positive describing safe
and effective treatments
but why were they banned and why don't
we use them
well they were banned remarkably in the
face of opposition the from this man
here Bobby Kennedy would have been
president if he hadn't been assassinated
the most powerful man in the world
who's talking to his his Regulators his
bureaucrats and he said to them why of
these clinical LSD projects we've spent
billions of dollars on them were
worthwhile six months ago why aren't
they worthwhile now
we keep going around and around
if I could get a flat answer about that
I'd be happy
is there a misunderstanding about my
question he knew he was being lied to
and he went on to say I think perhaps
we've lost sight of the fact that LSD
can be very very helpful on society
views properly I mean even he couldn't
stop this inexorable pressure of banning
things and won't be lost on any of you
that that process still goes on today
but the absurdity of banning everything
which has started back in the 1930s has
led to
the Banning of psychedelics and this is
the worst censorship of research in the
history of the world because they didn't
just ban these drugs for recreational
use of self-experimentation they banned
them for medical use even though they
were medicines no other drug that was a
medicine has been banned and the reason
they did that of course is because
psychedelics were changing the way
people viewed the conventional approach
of American foreign policy which was to
have a lot of bombs in Southeast Asia
but we're fighting back now and the
science is leading that
this graph just shows you how emphatic
this censorship has been so the blue
line is the number of papers
with LSD published each year and the red
with psilocybin
and you can see there's this massive
increase because there's a huge
investment in research and then after
the US bans in 67 the UN bands in 71
there's a cataclysmic fall off and there
are two reasons for that
one is that
the US government which was the way the
largest funder of research in the world
stopped funding any studies in fact they
haven't funded a study in nearly uh 55
years that just started last year uh and
the second is if you get money from
philanthropists to do this research you
couldn't get the drug because the DEA in
this FDA and the CIA effectively stopped
access and there was a deliberate
employee I think to eliminate all
knowledge of psychedelics and they
nearly succeeded like in 1919 91 there
was no single paper on silos library was
published
but you can see we're beginning to fight
back
so I'm going to move now into the
science of these drugs and I'll start
with the pharmacology so all these drugs
that I'm going to talk about which was
LSD DMT cytosibine mescaline they all
bind to the serotonin 2A receptor and
they all stimulate that receptor and so
do lots of other psychedelic drugs which
are on this chart but I'm not going to
detail these drugs turn on a serotonin
receptor in the brain and these
receptors
are remarkable because they're loaded
in the parts of the brain which are the
most recently evolved parts of the brain
the parts of the brain which distinguish
human brains from other primate brains
the parts of the brain in which we do
all these high level human tasks like
thinking about the future like imagining
new ways of Behaving new ways of doing
things inventing things uh socializing
this is that these receptors are more
densely expressed in human brain than
any other brain in these highly evolved
parts of the brain they seem to be
Central to the nature of human human
consciousness and and human and the
human brain has ability to do so many
more things than other brains
and they're on a particular group of
neurons in the brain and for those of
you who don't know much about
Neuroscience in a very simple way the
brain is like a three-dimensional
computer the first two dimensions of
these this Dimension uh these linear
dimensions in the cortex where each of
these rows of neurons are called a are
like a little computer and there's
there's hundreds of billions of these
little computers in your brain but
joining them all up to create the
massive power of the human brain which
has more power than all the computers on
Earth put together
the joining up of all these mini
computers is done by these layer five
pyramidal cells and they they're the
cells that connect across the brain
and that and they bring together this
massive computing power
and they're loaded with the receptors
these serotonin receptors and if you
stimulate these receptors with
psychedelics these cells depolarize like
crazy
they've produced a fundamentally
different state of activity and that
Ultras the connectivity of the brain in
a in a powerful way which it turns out
explains the loosening of a
Consciousness in the Psychedelic State
the generation of new ideas new ways of
thinking because we break down the
ongoing
classical ways in which the brain has
been functioning
but I'm getting my head ahead of myself
a little bit because I want to go
historically back to the very first
study we did which was published 10
years ago now
the first ever brain Imaging study using
fmri in
people who were given
a psychedelics are the same in
these results show a color coding which
is very important when you see these
images blue means less activity either
less blood flow or less brain activity
in our first study we found that our
volunteers who had full range of
interesting experiences hallucinations
the sense of their body morphing out
floating through space
one went to God and bowed at the foot of
God
and then they all came back and then we
analyzed their brains and we discovered
that there was no increased activity
anywhere there were just decreased is
inactivity
told us that Timothy Leary was wrong we
don't turn on the rain but we couldn't
quite make sense as to why turning off
the brain led to a psychedelic
experience
in fact we repeated it using a different
form of brain fmri Imaging cut the same
results and we came to the conclusion
that actually psychedelics were
disrupting brain function in a
fundamental way
particularly disrupting the centers of
the brain which you saw in our previous
image which turned out from other work
looking at the brain connectome to be
the hubs of brain activity there are two
main hubs they're put in and you can see
them here inside those yellow circles
the one at the front of the brain the
top one
is the frontal one the anterior
cingulate cortex and that integrates
your thinking you're planning your
anticipation your memory and your
emotions
and the one at the back the lower yellow
circle there that's a posterior Cingular
cortex and that integrates all your
senses your sense of of vision and
hearing and touch and proprioception and
smell Etc and those are the two
conductors of the brain's Orchestra and
we thought then that what was what's
happening with psychedelics is you were
switching off this control centers
you're taking the conductor out of the
orchestra and that allows the orcas to
decide what it wants to play itself
rather than be constrained to play what
the conductor tells it and that
liberation of brain activity is what
underpins the Psychedelic state
and what was really elegant about this
discovery of ours was it actually
fitted exactly we've got absolutely
predicted he said that the brain
controlled the mind and mescaline
in doing so producing the state of
altered Consciousness lower it does it
through lowering the efficiency of the
brain as an instrument for focusing the
mind so
that's now something we have shown
now if you change the way the brain
works you can actually get very
interesting outcomes so on the left hand
image here you see normal connectivity
in the brain and both of those two
images have got the same number of
connections but on the left hand side in
the normal brain most of the connections
around the edge that's called the small
world brain the visual cortex so it's
the visual cortex auditory cortex
auditory cortex of course there has to
be some crosstalk if you see a bus
bearing down on you you've got to get
your legs moving to run out of the way
but the massive efficiency of the brain
which is 10 times more efficient than
any human human-made computer
comes from the fact that most of the
connectivity is very local
energy efficient
but under psychedelics connectivity
massively increases and in fact what
you're doing here is you're putting
brain back to the state it was when
you're a young baby when all parts of
the brain could talk to each other and
one of the processes of of development
and education is to take this completely
flexible hyper-connected brain and
constrain it to the left-hand brain
where actually you can do things very
efficiently but in a very limited
fashion and in conditions like
depression or OCD that limitation can
become so hardwired that you actually do
things wrongly which are destructive to
you but you can't escape from them
this is a beautiful image from our paper
the first study ever of LSD using fmri
and you see here again the very limited
connectivity of the brain under Placebo
on the left and the massive connectivity
of the brain under LSD and that massive
connectivity the visual cortex those
green bits at the back they connect to
everywhere under LST and that's why
people have such profound and uh
memorable visual hallucinations
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas